after more than seven years of when are
you going to release your tax returns uh
probably over the next few months
they're being worked on right now well
I'm not really saying the tax returns
because as you know they're under audit
and a long legal and political battle
that eventually led to the Supreme Court
former president Donald Trump's tax
returns have been released and the
documents raise more questions about the
former president's taxes and how the IRS
handled them here's what we know and
don't know about Trump's finances and
why the returns were finally released
first the numbers through 2015 and 2020
the six years that were made public The
Joint return show that Donald and
Melania Trump's reported income varied
widely
for several years it was negative tens
of millions and then positive then
negative again for someone who's got
business income flowing into their
individual tax return it just doesn't
look like a wage or nurse tax return
it's it's different it is normal for
businesses whether it's real estate
business which particularly tends to
have a lot of deductions or just a
regular business that will have up years
and down years will go up and down with
the business cycle the amount of income
taxes paid varied widely too for two of
the years that they were in the red the
trumps only paid 750 dollars in income
taxes in another year they paid zero but
this was expected you have to be
surprised at how little I pay he didn't
pay any federal income tax so that makes
me smart yes he was not paying taxes
because he had losses that he claimed
but there's key questions about whether
those losses were legitimate and legal
and those are some of the things the IRS
is looking at another thing the IRS is
looking at millions in tax credits the
nonpartisan committee that released
system specifically wants the IRS to
look into foreign credits like this one
while Trump was in office
the committee also flagged Trump's
reported loans given to his children and
mentioned whether they could have been
potential gifts which should have been
taxed differently other questions Rose
around large charitable contributions
before his presidency but these are all
questions and not answers because the
IRS hasn't finished its audits the weird
things we have this like snapshot moment
where we have some information about him
but then things are going to change the
committee's report raised questions not
just for the continuing audit but around
the entire process its IRS policy for
the president and vice president to be
audited it happens to every
administration at least since the 1970s
because people have got to know whether
or not they're president's a crook well
I'm not a crook it's like a check on the
executive branch itself on someone who's
above the IRS
there's no formal process but audits are
generally done soon after the returns
are submitted So in theory the audit for
Trump's 2016 return should have started
in 2017 while he was president
2017's in 2018 you get it but instead
this is when the committee says those
audits began none began the first two
years of his presidency
the first one for 2015 began April 3rd
2019. that was the same day the house
committee chairman sent the first letter
to the IRS requesting Trump's tax
returns it was just three months after
Democrats took control of the house
after the midterm elections and
Democrats said getting Trump's tax
returns would be one of their first
actions and then I assumed that there
would be a court case that would go on
for a period of time he was right that
first letter kicked off a back and forth
between the committee and the Trump
Administration the treasury secretary
argued the law wasn't clear it is our
intent to follow the law and that is in
the process of being reviewed Mr Trump
and his treasury secretary are
stonewalling us but two years later the
new Biden administration's justice
department said the law showed the
treasury could release the returns and a
court battle began with Trump himself
suing to block the release it eventually
got to the Supreme Court they declined
to intervene defaulting to the last
appeals court
the committee had the right to the
returns by a week later they had them in
hand a month later they voted to release
the returns publicly oh it's a journey
and I was writing stories during the
2016 campaign about him saying he's
under audit and him saying he's not
going to release his returns voluntarily
so really it's a seven and a half year
legal and political fight over this Norm
of disclosure the returns likely won't
change anything for the former president
and 2024 presidential candidate but it
might change how the IRS handles these
presidential audits in the future
foreign
[Music]